le nombre de morts et de blessés ne
cesse d'augmenter dans le sud du Pérou
dans des affrontements avec les forces
de l'ordre
depuis deux jours environ 2000
manifestants tentaient de s'emparer de
l'aéroport de Rouillac près de Puno à la
frontière de la Bolivie l'un des plus
importants du pays car porte d'entrée de
tourisme
leurs armes des pierres des frondes et
des lance-roquettes artisanaux les
forces de l'ordre ripost avec gaz à
crimogènes des balles en caoutchouc et
on soupçonne de vraies balles
ce qui expliquerait le nombre de morts
et de blessés qui affluent à l'hôpital
municipal au point que le médecin chef
de son service d'urgence s'en prend au
gouvernement
centraliens
les protestataires exigent la démission
de la présidente par intérim
dynabolwarte
démissionné beaucoup de gens meurent par
votre faute le peuple ne veut plus de
vous ce qu'ils veulent c'est le retour
du président destitué Pedro Castillo cet
ancienne instituteur rural est en prison
pour rébellion après sa destitution le 7
décembre par le Congrès pour tentative
de coup d'État en deux ans et demi ces
quatre gouvernements ont été marqués par
une grande instabilité et de nombreux
soupçons de corruption il a été remplacé
par sa vice-présidente d'inaboluerte qui
n'a de cesse de lancer les appels au
dialogue
en vous tendons la main et le coeur
rejoignez le gouvernement discutant de
vos raisons de protester et mettons fin
à ces manifestations
le droit à la protestation s'arrête
quand on viole les droits d'autrui or si
elle est du même parti de gauche
marxiste péroubré que Pedro Castillo
elle est rejetée par les manifestants
qui se concentre davantage dans le sud
rural et indigène à Imara du pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le Pérou est profondément divisé sur une
base politique droite-gauche mais aussi
urbaine rural avec une connotation
raciale Jean-Michel Leprince a du Canada
Montréal